surtout les 10 dernières années,
une sécheresse violente et croissante a frappé
le sud-ouest des États-Unis,
et il s'est avéré que les colonies qui préservent l'eau,
qui ne sortent pas quand il fait vraiment chaud dehors,
qui ne vont donc pas récolter le maximum de nourriture,
sont celles les plus susceptibles d'avoir des colonies filles.
Je pensais que la colonie 154
était du côté des perdantes car, les jours très secs,
elle ne récoltait qu'à peine,
alors que les autres colonies
sortaient, et récoltaient beaucoup,
mais, en fait, la colonie 154 est une grande réussite.
C'est une chef de famille.
C'est une des rares arrière-grand-mère du site
A ma connaissance, c'est la première fois
qu'a pu être observée
l'évolution d'un comportement collectif
d'une population animale en milieu naturel,
et pu être mis ainsi à jour ce qui fonctionne, de fait, le mieux.
Internet utilise un algorithme
pour réguler les flux de données
qui est très proche de celui
que les fourmis utilisent pour réguler
les flux de moissonneuses.
On ne devrait plus parler de la Toile...
... mais de la Fourmilière.
(Applaudissements)
Ainsi, un ordinateur ne transmet des données
que si un signal indique qu'il y a assez de bande passante
pour les acheminer.
Quand, au début d'Internet,
les coûts de fonctionnement étaient très élevés,
et qu'il était très important de ne pas perdre de données,
le système s'est organisé pour que ce soit
les interactions qui activent le flux de données.
Il est intéressant que les fourmis utilisent
un algorithme aussi proche que celui que nous avons inventé,
mais ce n'est qu'un des rares algorithmes
que nous connaissons,
alors que les fourmis ont eu 130 millions d'années
pour en développer de nombreux autres,
et il y a de grandes chances
pour que certaines des 12 000 autres espèces
disposent d'algorithmes intéressants
pour les réseaux
auxquels nous n'avons pas encore pensé.
Que se passe-t-il quand les coûts de fonctionnement sont faibles?
Ils le sont sous les tropiques,
grâce à l'humidité, qui permet aux fourmis
de sortir récolter sans aucune peine.
Mais les fourmis y sont
si nombreuses et si variées,
que la compétition y est intense.
Quand une espèce utilise une ressource,
il est très probable qu'une autre espèce l'utilise aussi
au même moment.
Dans ce type de milieu, les interactions sont utilisées
de façon opposée.
Le système tourne, sauf si
quelque chose de négatif arrive.
Une espèce que j'étudie fait des tours
dans les arbres de fourmis moissonneuses,
des allers-retours du nid à la source de nourriture,
continuellement, sauf si
un événement négatif arrive,
par exemple un contact
avec une fourmi d'une autre espèce.
Voici un exemple de défense chez les fourmis.
Au milieu, une fourmi
bloque l'entrée du nid avec sa tête,
en réponse aux contacts avec les fourmis d'une autre espèce,
les petites que l'on voit autour,
avec leurs abdomens pointés vers le haut.
Mais dès que la menace est passée
l'entrée s'ouvre de nouveau,
et, peut-être, il y a des cas
en sécurité informatique
où les coûts de fonctionnement sont assez bas
pour que l'on puisse simplement bloquer un accès temporairement,
en réponse à une menace immédiate,
avant de l'ouvrir de nouveau,
plutôt que de construire
un pare-feu permanent ou une forteresse.
Un autre défi
que rencontre tout système
est celui des ressources, qu'il faut trouver et collecter.
Les fourmis résolvent le problème
de la recherche collective,
un problème de grande importance
en robotique,
parce que nous avons compris que,
plutôt que d'envoyer un seul
robot sophistiqué et coûteux
pour explorer une planète
ou un bâtiment en flammes,
il était plus efficace
de réunir plusieurs robots moins coûteux
échangeant entre eux des informations basiques,
de la même manière que les fourmis.
La fourmi, invasive, d'Argentine
met en place des réseaux de recherche extensibles.
Elle traite efficacement le principal problème
de la recherche collective,
qui est le compromis à trouver entre
rechercher minutieusement
et couvrir le plus de terrain possible.
En pratique,
quand elles sont nombreuses dans un petit espace,
chacune recherche très minutieusement,
parce qu'il y a une autre fourmi
juste à côté,
mais quand il y a peu de fourmis
dans un large espace,
chacune allonge son parcours
pour couvrir plus de terrain.
Je pense que leurs interactions servent à estimer la densité.
Quand l'espace est bondé,
elles se rencontrent
plus souvent, et cherchent plus minutieusement
Des espèces différentes doivent utiliser des algorithmes différents,
car chacune a évolué pour s'occuper
de ressources différentes,
et il serait très utile de le savoir.
Nous avons demandé à des fourmis
de résoudre le problème de la recherche collective
dans l'environnement extrême
qu'est la micropesanteur,
dans la Station Spatiale Internationale.
Voyant cette photo, j'ai pensé :
« Oh non, ils l'ont mis à la verticale ! »,
avant de réaliser que, bien sûr, c'était sans importance.
L'idée, c'est que les fourmis
fassent tant d'efforts pour s'accrocher
au mur ou, si vous préférez, au plafond,
qu'elles ont moins de chances d'interagir,
et que le lien entre
densité et fréquence des rencontres
soit perturbé.
Nous analysons les données.
Je n'ai pas encore les résultats.
Mais il serait intéressant de savoir
comment d'autres espèces règlent ce problème
dans différents milieux du monde.
Nous créons un programme
pour encourager les enfants du monde entier
à faire cette expérience avec différentes espèces.
C'est très simple.
Le matériel nécessaire est peu coûteux.
Et, ainsi, nous pourrions créer une carte mondiale
des algorithmes de recherche collective des fourmis.
Je pense qu'il est probable que les espèces invasives,
celles qui viennent dans nos bâtiments,
soient très douées pour ça,
car, si elles sont dans votre cuisine,
c'est parce qu'elles sont douées pour trouver à boire et à manger.
La ressource la plus connue des fourmis,
c'est un pique-nique,
et il s'agit d'une ressource concentrée.
S'il y a un fruit,
il est probable qu'il y en ait un autre à côté,
et les fourmis spécialisées dans les ressources concentrées
utilisent les interactions pour recruter.
Quand l'une croise une autre,
ou tombe sur une substance
déposée sur le sol par une autre,
elle change alors de direction,
suit celle de l'interaction,
et vous avez des fourmis en file indienne
partageant votre pique-nique.
Je pense que l'on aurait ici
quelque chose à apprendre des fourmis sur le cancer.
Bien sûr, on peut faire beaucoup
pour éviter le cancer,
en interdisant aux gens de répandre
ou de vendre les toxines qui favorisent
le développement du cancer dans nos corps,
mais je ne pense pas que l'on puisse là s'inspirer
des fourmis, car elles n'empoisonnent jamais leur propre colonie.
Mais on peut s'en inspirer
pour le traitement du cancer.
Il y a de nombreux types de cancer.
Chacun commence dans un endroit particulier du corps,
avant, pour certains, de se répandre
- de métastaser- vers d'autres tissus,
où ils obtiennent les ressources dont ils ont besoin.
Si l'on se met à la place
de métastases de cellules cancéreuses,
qui cherchent autour d'elles
les ressources dont elles ont besoin,
si ces ressources sont concentrées,
elles utilisent probablement les interactions pour recruter,
et si nous pouvons comprendre comment ces cellules recrutent,
alors, peut-être, nous pourrions mettre des pièges
pour les attraper avant qu'elles ne soient bien installées.
Les fourmis utilisent donc les interactions de différentes façons,
dans une grande variété de milieux,
et elles peuvent nous aider à comprendre
d'autres systèmes qui fonctionnent
sans gestion centralisée.
En n'utilisant que des interactions simples,
les colonies de fourmis ont pu
réaliser des choses incroyables pendant plus de 130 millions d'années.
Nous avons beaucoup à apprendre d'elles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)